over the past year i've covered
countless videos of cities burning and
innocent people attacked
by mostly peaceful protesters these
scenes
are usually pretty terrible but things
do not
always go the way that mostly peaceful
protesters are hoping
my producer has compiled a list of the
funniest antifa blm
and rioter fails of the year first i
should mention this video is sponsored
by my bookie
the best place to place bets on sports
events of all kinds
more on them later but for now let's
check out some of the most delightful
mostly peaceful protest videos okay the
first one
is the most coherent reason for
protesting yet let's watch
brings you guys out tonight um we are
we live in this neighborhood and
we are anti-trump okay
i'm trying to get the other side in
there so are you here to
protest or support biden like how would
you categorize it we're here to support
our family
and our people
against whatever trump is
for well i think he's probably just for
getting better right now
we don't care how he's feeling okay well
that's about
it and i think that's about as
articulate an explanation as i've ever
heard what do you oppose uh
trump and what are you for uh not trump
i'm i'm for whatever not trump okay
that's good that actually was mostly
peaceful though they were you know there
wasn't like
weren't setting buildings on fire or
anything so i give them more credit than
than most of these guys next one is
skateboard kyle goes for the kill shot
[Music]
shrimpy antifa guy and then this just
giant hulking conservative man
just like he's like barely even looking
at him and then the kid throws a punch
just like
nope sorry try again all right
i'll go back did not expect that i love
man that giant guy just keeps us cool
the whole time it's good no worries
next one is the molotov cocktail karma
[Music]
[Laughter]
yup that's
oh yikes there's another one oh man oh
no
oh that other guy just caught his nikes
on fire but this guy caught his whole
body
there is a real lesson in here by the
way when you try
to set the flag on fire
when you try to set federal buildings on
fire
when you try to set your fellow american
citizens on fire
sometimes you will accidentally catch
yourself on fire
when you try to destroy your country you
often
almost inevitably you might say will
destroy yourself
as those poor schlubs found out okay now
this one they tell me i've got to guess
what's going on in this video this
is called defiant feminist halts traffic
what happens next can't wait to see
[Music]
what happens next does anybody have any
bets on what happens next well if you do
have a bet i would recommend
you go check out my bookie it is betting
season of my bookie you know that i love
a good political bet every now and again
i actually have right here
is a the winnings of a bet i made with
one mr ben shapiro
four years ago during the 2016
presidential election there we go thank
you
absolutely no no no don't worry i mobile
deposited it so it's not like he got to
keep the money
mobile deposited then obviously uh
framed it for the studio
if you like fun election bets you got to
check out my book you can bet on the
winner of the presidential election
the day the loser will concede the race
they've got betting opportunities for
the final presidential
debate will joe biden call president
trump a racist well that's not that's an
easy bet there are a lot of other bets
too though whether you've been betting
for years or you are ready to play for
the first time
my bookie is your go-to this season with
the biggest online selection of bets and
props
mybookie has made it simple to win and
easy to withdraw your cash head on over
to mybookie
to create an account just use the promo
code knowlescannerwlis to claim your 100
deposit match
that's all the way up to a thousand
dollars which means if you put a hundred
dollars in they're gonna give you
another hundred dollars it's an easy way
to jumpstart your bankroll nfl nba mlb
everything else
they've got it all on tap and it is
never too late to get started on your
winning season
only at my bookie all right any bets on
what happens next
i don't have any bets i'm too ner i'm
too nervous for this gal let's see what
happens
[Music]
oh that's that's not nice that's
that's actually see this is like why
ah that's i mean it the thing is the
reason that's not
funny is because it's a woman like if it
were a guy it would be absolutely
hilarious
but i i actually don't get any pleasure
from seeing
even the most shrill leftist crazy woman
get knocked in the head with something
because i just think like
lady you shouldn't be here you should be
like in a nice place
with like i don't know with like your
friends and your family and your
children and
like enjoying life instead of standing
on a
rainy street waiting to get run over by
a car
until some other guy throws a traffic
cone at your head not
not a good state of society it's like
almost like the cultural revolution of
the last 60 years hasn't been great
for all of us and women in particular
next one the real reason guys go
protesting
in portland
is that a chick oh that is a chick it's
hard to tell because it's kind of
leaked out yeah
[Music]
i don't think it works if you're
if you're standing behind the gal with
the shield so that you can get a look
at this completely naked lady i have to
say oh no you know this is
this is obviously pixelated out because
this is a family program
but very often women of the far
left are not like aphrodite you know
they are not
sort of uh classical visions
of physical beauty but i don't know she
looked
kind of nice looking and apparently that
antifa fella
was interested in taking a gander as
well next up
times are hard in democrat cities when
even celebrities are looting
and stealing bread to survive
does that count as a kovid mask i think
you're a
giant elmo head that is the most
whimsical way to steal property i think
i've ever seen
you put on just like a big silly cartoon
mask it's tough out there though i don't
know and you know those republicans are
cutting all the funding from sesame
street so
they got to eat they got it's not a sin
if you're stealing bread to feed your
family next up police get absolutely
served by blm
see i i'm not one
to always look for a psychological
explanation
to strange political ideas and behaviors
but there's obviously something
psychologically broken
about these far left protesters like
when they're kind of dancing around all
wacky in front of cops and things like
that or when you look at the people who
show up to antifa and a ton of them were
just
felons and like one guy was a pedophile
it was like very prominent because i
think he got shot by that conservative
kid in
in kenosha all these people have like
real
psychological damage and the ones that
are shrieking and
screaming like something tells me they
don't have the nicest home life in the
world they don't like
you know have lovely thanksgiving
dinners around the fireplace and good
old dad like
throws them football or something like
that there obviously is something that's
that has broken in the psyche of america
and that's obviously going to have
effects on society when you're
when you've got a lot of personal
problems the left told us decades ago
the personal is the political when
you've got a ton of personal problems
when you like
your entire personal life is just
totally warped
that is going to have political effect
and we're seeing that prance around
and dance around on the streets of
american cities all right last one
classic
protester gets reality checked
you just saw one of the protesters go up
there and actually kick a can of that
yeah that are kicking the peppers
oh gosh right there right
that is unbelievable aim from
presumably law enforcement and a guy
just got shot with a rubber bullet
wow that looks very painful i i i
wouldn't say that's my favorite one just
because
you just have a kind of empathetic
response if you were a man to that
unfortunate
experience but i would say my favorite
one was probably the molotov cocktails
the guys setting themselves on fire
because there's so much
symbolism to it these are people who are
trying to burn down their countrymen
burn down buildings burn the american
flag
burn our country to the ground and they
wind up not burning any of those
innocent people in institutions
they end up burning themselves and
that's what happens that's what happens
when you
attack your own country a little levity
amid
months and months and months of chaos
mayhem and destruction a little a little
bit of levity in there do you think
these leftists learned any lesson from
it probably not let me know your
favorites in the comments section if you
have any more videos that we can
we can enjoy just as a little silver
lining
to this crazy leftist storm
[Music]
you